bonjour à tous quand on leur cours et
pour ce nouveau numéro c dans le sud de
l'île que je vous emmène plus exactement
à manapany néo où on va aller partager
le quotidien de didier sceaux s y
installer sa ferme-auberge ici je pense
qu on a fait trop loin
bada
il est temps quand on est sur la bonne
voie
et on voit
pas de doute on est bien au bon endroit
ferme auberge dina et on va voir si
notre hôte est présent oui arrive oui à
lui guillaume bon tu vois ça va et toi
faut alors bien prendre un peu d annuler
owens minutes et un petit coup de mou
avait génial mais en plus il tombe bien
nous les nuls en plein dedans là bas sa
cuisine c'est bon ça va ça va j'ai battu
mercredi à londres
ces progrès de ceux ci soient bafing
oui et j'ai encore jamais goûté ça abbas
est bon ben voilà l'occasion les langues
mais à part ça du coup la coop à deux
coups même capacité ton taf en modèle la
gîte de groupe pour 9 personnes
ouais et là un petit chalet pour couples
principalement avec capacité deux
adultes deux enfants
donc c'est possible de venir apprécier
un petit week-end avec sa chérie par
l'afp voilà avait tout à fait c'est fait
pour ces faits quoi bon alors ils sont
cachés ou thema fils nova coupe ça l'a
déjà fait peur avec tout type et en plus
il tombe bien on a un régime banane pour
couper racines réseau va manger tout bon
évidemment un petit coup de main alors
là oui je suis là pour sa chef
allez lequel nous travaillons
bas-madawaska il faut pas non non là il
faut récupérer gindt ensuite on battait
pour pâques rajoute c'est bon j attends
je les biens moment pas de doute c'est
bon à l'épaule doucement maintenant la
suite de tensions demain si bon ok super
ça c'est fait voilà où un oral des siens
possible le midi on peut pour manger la
wii elle est tombée cariou
bon bah écoute pas ça un instant allons
récupérer va pas maintenant
il en faut combien faut préparer le
cahier lectures faire là se trouvent
trois ou quatre très bien la carte tient
la partie
oui
en fait comment tu sais ces prêts ou
c'est pas prêt la raison pourquoi le
graphique entre les bananes et les
banaboo de bois n'a plus rien donc là on
reconnaît que les frappes idoine a donc
là un des super mi moyens
bon alors notre boîte à face à de
pareilles ma fille ou passe à l'ara pour
moi ou connecte quand voir il faut aussi
par en dedans la wii ware est comme ça
au moins on n'a pas cela qui donne le
goût un petit peu de la grève et du coup
en faisant comme ça où on récupère
traitement ou voir m'ont donné un petit
peu de rouge donc ça allait pas
désagréable est pas grave ça c'est paul
hus c'est plus la petite banane le fruit
même que comme c'est un petit fou il est
pas encore mature c'est puis ça qu'on va
donner un petit goût désagréable en fait
mais en faisant comme ça ça va quoi
voilà on commence à arriver au petit
petite banane intérieure et donc du coup
tu préfères tu proposes quoi la carte là
parce que là on entre la cuisine et à
roubaix saucisses ben voilà mais c'est
pas comme toujours pareil c'est pas le
principe de restaurant le restaurant où
arrive on va demander ça ça et là c'est
pas du tout le cas là sera plus le repas
en fonction de ce que la table il peut
proposer
donc on abat naf rougail saucisses bas
ma fille à l'esa des produits voilà des
produits longtemps des tirs pas
traditionnel par en général d'ailleurs
pas traditionnel vous pour essayer du
tout simple poulets canards fort que
lapins les trucs comme ça et après me
fait aussi bien les repas de famille
tout ce que les repas non pas du fait de
ses origines fait les communions les
baptêmes et anniversaire les petits
mariage les repas de comité d'entreprise
voilà il travaille avec des produits les
producteurs locaux
que ce soit au niveau des hauts niveaux
des légumes au niveau des viandes et
tout ça c'est pas donc c'est des trucs
comme à la fois à dispo sur votre style
à deux tours ou trouve de tout c'est
quoi ces des produits bio pas forcément
bio mais raisonné d'avoir un coup là si
tu veux voir la différence entre les
sociétés lambda et des vrais saucisses
ça c'est de la vraie saucisses même au
bout et arrive à reconnaître le scénario
c'est six mois il chante mieux elles
sont mûres dragons sont plus forts
l'agriculture est encore très ancrée
comme il dit la petite île ville à la
campagne on à la fête de l'art il a fait
des agrumes la fête la fête du temps
encore pourquoi il a choisi la commune
de petite île comme élevé de ces
versements et petit noir mât est né et
grandi petit ils n'ont petite-ilois de
naissance et ce terrain là c'était un
terrain qui appartenait à mon grand père
c'est quoi des fleurs la valeur des lcd
pleurs
voilà après une matinée passée dans la
cuisine à préparer ce magnifique
ou est ce si ce n'est pas fini on va
maintenant passer à table et il sait me
repasser sacré donc en ce qui concerne
la caméra
et c'est on a bien mangé oui merci
penseront pas d'ailleurs ben écoute avec
plaisir je garderai ça en tête la roue
et saucisses baba fixe je rentrais chez
moi
et du coup pour la digestion et a décidé
de m'emmener faire une petite balade
ouais est ce que tu peux me dire où est
ce qu'on est alors là au piton de
grand-anse temps grand-anse du côté du
côté bas du côté saint pierre ducout
donc là avec la vue justement sur le
bassin de gros temps cela mon pain béni
en toute sécurité et dans les eaux là
justement c'est l'hôtel et en montant
tout droit là c'est la commune une
petite île à une partie pâtissier une
porte saint-pierre montvert donc on a
une belle gueule donc une belle vue un
endroit calme avec une vue assez lâches
et l'océan pour effectivement on est
juste à côté de chez soi
bah oui à peine 15 minutes ouais bon sur
la plage
je
j'aurais bien profiter de ces petits
moments de calme n'a en fin de journée
pour parler un peu plus de toit allez un
petit peu plus de ce qui t'a amené à ce
métier de ferme aubergiste et de ton
parcours
juste avant c'était un snack restaurant
et moi très bien travaillé aussi bien
dans le dans le domaine administratif
dont on a été dans les bureaux on a été
sur le terrain et à un moment c'est un
retour aux sources ne les remet à l'été
avait une grande ferme une grande basse
quoi dans le dans la bande à kouadio du
coc et donc toute mon enfance arrivé là
bas ma place était dans la basse cour au
milieu des canards des poules et des
pigeons des lapins c'est de retour aux
sources mais retour aux sources
peut-être pourquoi peut-être pour
retrouver ce côté calme apaisant de la
nature que retrouve certainement pas
dans un bureau on retrouve certainement
pas dans un travail avec des collègues
avec donc on n'a pas ça là dedans et on
a pu voir aussi que certains de tes
meubles tu faisais à la main j'aide à
ses meubles et structures meubles
structure est effectivement le chalet au
cnda le fait comme ça autonome c'est
quelque chose d'important pour fadi
penser plus à une façon de de
matérialiser des souhaits des envies des
rêves c'est des trucs que l'était
peut-être là en dormance à l'intérieur
et que là était de matérialiser à un
moment et heureusement d'ailleurs que
mal à ses capacités de faire donc d'une
certaine manière finalement toute cette
ferme auberge dinas c'est une
extériorisation de tes rêves
oui exactement s'il affirme dina
comme vous pouvez le voir à mater pour
vient de se réveiller
c'est une matinée qui débute ici à la
ferme auberge dina qui dit ferme auberge
10 fermes qui dit ferme des animaux et
si chaque matin commence par l'entretien
des animaux et je vais le rejoindre
didier qui doit déjà être en train de
s'affairer c'est quand même super
agréable de se révéler au genre de gars
or a bien dormi ça va ça va abbas si
j'avais su j'aurais attendu pour prendre
la douche a donc du coup cette actu leur
donne à manger à des cochons ça ouais en
gros sur les autres un petit aperçu de
ce qu'on m'a pas fini hier soir en fait
donc tu as des cochons oui c'est un
canard j'ai entendu des cadres y crie un
petit peu par l'ama cabris moutons
quelques moutons s'accroît de poulet je
me dis ouais lapin lapin dadon iliad a
dont je pas sûr qu'elle apprécie n'est
gratuit ou alors c'est par la danse
ils sont adorables et elle a du coup
simplement le code pour tout est changé
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses
géniales la basse-cour de la grand mère
la tante et l'animateur qui faisait ça
tous les matins
non la banane mais ce que des profits là
bas c'est quand y arriver tout est fini
c'est un ciel voilé canada il apprécie
cqp des animaux
juste faire gaffe aux faisans c'est quoi
son nom à n'a pas de nom n'a pas de nom
à paris faisant me donne pas de nom en
général les animaux et j'imagine que son
statut de la scott le préserve de tout
ah oui les élus est de presque deux
marmites de tout risque de cuisson
succès à l'écriture c'est pas la chance
que tu attends la petite chance secret
du coup les pigeons c'est pareil c'est
juste pour l'atteindre pédagogique ce
travail quel type de public du coup pour
la ferme alors le public c bat déjà tous
publics
après les écoles et puis battu les
personnes handicapées les enfants ou
adultes handicapées ou âgées
donc c'est plus une forme découverte
ferme découverte des grands clubs ça du
coup c'est important pour toi quand tu
as ouvert conjugue une régie d'avoir un
espace là à côté là où partager ce
plaisir
bon ben on va devoir y aller tant merci
pour tout bon plaisir tournage et n'a
pas vraiment le temps de dire au revoir
à tous les pensionnaires dont une fois
pour moi et puis à très très vite il
yad'autres 4 mai pour ça donc j'ai dit
baye et bien c'est là dessus que va se
tenir cet épisode alors je sais pas pour
vous mais moi j'ai vraiment passé un
excellent moment en compagnie de didier
qui au passage nous rappeler qu'avec une
petite dose de fois une grande dose pour
le coup de coude il est possible d'aller
au bout de chacun de nos rêves
ceci mis à part si vous avez envie de
passer un petit week end en amoureux si
vous avez envie de découvrir la culture
culinaire local ou simplement la vie à
la ferme
je donne l'adresse ça se passe à la
ferme auberge dit la compagnie didier
solace ici sur la commune de petite île
en ce qui nous concerne on se retrouve
très très vite sur les routes de la
réunion a plus
du